si padece diabetes gestacional durante
el embarazo
el nivel de azúcar en el torrente
sanguíneo es más alto de lo normal
el azúcar en la sangre se denomina
glucosa
una hormona del cuerpo llamada insulina
actúa como una llave en una cerradura
cuando se adhiere a los receptores de
las células
la insulina abre las células para que la
glucosa pueda ingresar
ahora las células pueden usar la glucosa
para producir la energía necesaria y
funcionar de manera adecuada
una glándula llamada páncreas produce
toda la insulina que las células
necesitan para usar la glucosa
se desconoce la causa exacta de la
diabetes gestacional
sin embargo el órgano que une a su bebé
con el útero y la placenta produce
hormonas que podrían evitar que la
insulina deje entrar la glucosa a sus
células
como resultado la glucosa de la sangre
se eleva por encima del nivel normal en
lo que se denomina hiperglucemia la
hiperglucemia es la marca distintiva de
cualquier tipo de diabetes
si no se mantienen los niveles de
glucosa en sangre dentro del intervalo
normal podría desarrollar complicaciones
tales como presión sanguínea alta
además hay un riesgo mayor de un parto
prematuro
y un parto por cesárea en el cual los
médicos sacan al bebé a través de una
incisión en su abdomen
su bebé también puede tener riesgo de
complicaciones después de nacer entre
ellas peso elevado al nacer llamado
macrosomía
nivel bajo de azúcar en la sangre
llamado hipoglucemia un color amarillo
en la piel del bebé conocido como
ictericia y dificultad para respirar
la diabetes gestacional generalmente
desaparece después del nacimiento del
bebé
el objetivo al tratar la diabetes
estacional es mantener la glucosa en
sangre dentro del intervalo objetivo
normal
puede hacerlo creando un plan de
alimentación saludable con su proveedor
de atención médica o un nutricionista
certificado
la actividad física y el ejercicio
también pueden ayudarle a mantener el
nivel de glucosa en sangre dentro del
intervalo objetivo normal
su médico podría pedirle que revise el
nivel de glucosa en sangre regularmente
con un medidor de glucosa para revisar
su nivel de glucosa en sangre debe
insertar una tira reactiva en el medidor
de glucosa
luego debe pincharse el dedo y colocar
unas gotas de sangre en la tira reactiva
el medidor de glucosa medirá y mostrará
su nivel de glucosa en sangre
si padece diabetes estacional la
asociación americana de la diabetes
recomienda los siguientes intervalos
objetivos para el nivel de glucosa en
sangre
95 - antes de una comida
140 o menos una hora después de una
comida
y 120 o menos dos horas después de una
consulte con su médico para conocer su
intervalo objetivo específico
si no puede mantener el nivel de glucosa
en sangre dentro del intervalo objetivo
normal con dieta y ejercicio es posible
que su médico le recete insulina
y le muestre cómo administrársela usted
mismo
puede prevenir la diabetes estacional
mediante
el asesoramiento pre concept y vo en el
cual consultar a su obstetra antes de
quedar embarazada para planificar un
embarazo saludable la pérdida del exceso
de peso antes del embarazo
el ejercicio regular antes y durante el
embarazo
y una alimentación saludable